[Musique]
qu'il soit sur plateau en vidéo ou même
en réalité virtuelle le jeu sous toutes
ses nuances est de plus en plus
plébisité une tendance qui s'est
observée lors de la 9e édition de
festigieux à Villepreux plus de 4000
personnes sont venues au gymnase Alain
Mimoun les 3 et 4 février derniers soit
1000 de plus que l'année précédente
c'est vraiment une bonne occasion de
rencontrer de nouvelles personnes de
faire de nouvelles activités et juste de
trouver quelque chose de nouveau on
croise vraiment des gens d'un peu
partout c'est chouette ouais et puis on
fait découvrir ce qu'on fait aussi bonne
expérience on reviendra on refera
d'autres festival de jeu comme ça parce
que c'était très chouette le retour à la
mode du jeu se confirme auprès de toutes
les générations depuis quelques années
le monde du jeu en fait a beaucoup
évolué avec le l'arrivée du covid les
gens ont commencé à jouer chez eux et
ont découvert le jeu qui se limitait pas
aux jeux de base qui sont ce que connaît
tout le monde le Monopoly la bonne paye
ou autre maintenant il y a une quantité
de jeux phénoménale et on tout le monde
peut y trouver son compte petit comme
grand je fais du jeu de rôle depuis les
années 90 on a eu un je dis on a eu
c'est pas moi spécialement mais il y a
eu un trou dans les années 2000 et ça
s'est inversé depuis quelques années et
ouis y a beaucoup plus de joueurs un
moment d'amusement et d'échange le jeu
permet aussi de développer des
compétences comme celles du travail en
équipe exemple avec ce jeu de plateau
c'est un jeu parfait pour l'initiation
sur le dungeon crawler les joueurs
interprètent un héros qui va devoir euh
fouiller dans un donjon et et combattre
les monstres et réussir la mission qui
lui a était confiée c'est un jeu de
coopération donc ça force les joueurs à
jouer ensemble à interagir ensemble et à
compter les uns sur les autres chacun
chaque joueur a des compétences qui qui
sont différentes de celle des autres
donc c'est un c'est un jeu vraiment bien
pour pour apprendre à travailler
ensemble et les possibilités ne manquent
pas plus de 150 éditeurs existent en
France ces sociétés fabriquent de plus
en plus leurs produits directement dans
l'Hexagone c'est le cas de ce jeu le jeu
qu'on propose ici c'est infiltré donc
infiltré c'est un petit jeu de bluff un
petit jeu d'ambiance qui se joue de de
jusqu'à 12 joueurs et donc c'est nous
qui l'avons créé donc c'est notre
deuxième jeu qu'on a sorti juste au
moment du covid le jeu encore de belles
heures devant lui près de 9 Français sur
10 se retrouveraiit régulièrement autour
de jeux de société le chiffre d'affaires
de leur vente a même augmenté de 20 % en